Emily Maynard confirmed she's expecting
her fourth child with hubby Tyler
Johnson and her pregnancy has had one
major complication the former
bachelorette took to Instagram on
Tuesday sharing this adorable video
showcasing her growing belly she
captioned it way too many tacos at lunch
we can't wait for number four to get
here and went on to detail her pregnancy
cravings which include hot wings and
ranch dressing then she dropped this
bomb quote an emergency appendix surgery
at six months thankfully all seems to be
well now the 31 year old mom explaining
she wouldn't change it for the world
Emily also revealed she's due in the
next couple of weeks
and says the sex of her baby will be a
surprise Maynard and Johnson tied the
knot in June 2014 you may now kiss your
wife
they're already proud parents to
two-year-old Jennings bye-bye love you
I'll see you later and 11 month old
Gibson Emily also has a 12 year old
daughter Ricki from a previous
relationship with late race car driver
Ricky Hendrick pizza girl ET caught up
with the soon-to-be mom of four last
December she opened up about having two
sons so close in age the third has been
the hardest adjustment Jennings took his
first like consecutive ten steps in the
hospital like right after I had had
Gibson
I'm like no to huge milestone yeah like
I'm not ready